don't listen to everybody that says no
for every one of your ideas because
you're gonna get you know
100 for every every you know yes you get
so you know have the passion
[Music]
are y'all titling good morning good
morning how you doing
i'm doing well how are you today good
it's an interesting time i feel like
everybody's almost adjusted to this new
normal right
yeah i mean i don't know if you want to
call it normal but it certainly is a uh
a new a new way of experiencing life
definitely i mean you know after you
know what has it been like 12 weeks
already
waking up and just opening the computer
and getting ready for the first meeting
not even thinking about
which office you have to go to i mean
that's unfortunately for me already
becoming a new norm
but but we can only be hopeful are we
all such an impressive background and i
can't wait to talk to you about
about scaling and about cyber security
and your different experiences
from an mba at wharton to being a
to being an executive within netflix and
and really overseeing some incredible
incredible
scale and different and different
challenges there that i'd love to hear
about
and now going to be a partner at scale
venture partners
and sitting on the boards of some
incredible companies like honeycomb and
perimeter x
whom i admire uh ariel who are you give
me a little bit of a rundown and then i
have some
some deep dives that i want to do with
you sure
um so i first i'll give you the
geographical history
so originally from georgia in the former
soviet union the country not the state
which is
something i would like to preface or
post fix that with
i moved at a young age to israel spent
about seven years there
growing up as a kid and then um my dad
got a job here in the bay area and moved
here
at the end of middle school and uh and
lived in the bay area ever since
from uh from a career standpoint it
really followed my father's footsteps he
was uh
back he was a software engineer back
when they weren't called software
engineers
and i just really taught me the the ins
and outs of uh
of programming and i enjoyed that from
just a very young age so when did you
start programming
second when did you start programming i
started programming back in israel
gosh i think i was um so i left to zero
when i was ten
and this was a couple of years before i
left so probably seven eight
wow my mom signed me up for seven or
eight
a basic programming class for uh for
teenagers but
she had some kind of a connection there
i was able to get me in early because i
was just very interested in it
i mean you know today with you know code
monkey and all these different softwares
if you're seven and eight and you're not
coding yet you're a little bit out of
the game but
but you know in your time going to
program at seven or eight that's pretty
unheard of
yeah it was uh it was fine i got my
first uh
camera 64 which was the first computer i
played around with and
and had um just incredible amount of fun
with it so
you know when i came when i came to the
states i kind of knew what what my
career path was without thinking about
it too much so i went and got
computer science degree from uc berkeley
and uh started out as a software
engineer you know had an incredible
um uh you know fulfilling time doing it
for for a number of years and then you
know kind of got a little
a little bored with just the the coding
side of it and um
and i was at siebel systems at the time
and
the company was growing like crazy this
was back in the
late 90s and uh got the opportunity to
manage a team
so said hey why not this looks
interesting and there's a different
challenge a challenge that i don't
understand anything about so
um what could possibly go wrong and so
you know started a challenge i started
managing a team and
you know really went into engineering
management from there what was it like
doing that transition from an engineer
to managing a team of engineers
i made that transition early in in the
idf and it was a little bit different
from what i expected it to be
yeah you know i it um i really enjoyed
it um it
particularly back then as a first time
and i think you know these days stu as a
first line manager
i mean you're really kind of bridging
the gap between being the um one of the
experts from the expert from a technical
side which is what got you
successful and got you the opportunity
to become a manager to
you know learning how to handle the
human side of it and the interpersonal
side of it and a team and dynamics
of it and so i this is
i think a common thread that goes
through my
um selection process when i think about
opportunities and
on the job side as well as as well as
project side is you know i don't
if i don't feel like i am learning more
than i am teaching
then i just get a little bit bored in a
particular role that i'm in so for that
it was like this is a whole new world
right i don't understand very much about
it it sounds really interesting and so i
went you know i took
uh uh the sible at the time had a bunch
of um
uh internal classes that i took around
situational leadership and you know you
know the usual slate
yeah i did try to kind of get up to
speed on being a first time manager and
yeah i loved all that
um and so it was it was a very different
set of muscles uh that that you have to
build um
you know you have to know how to talk
and understand people rather than code
which is which is a
very different code is much more
predictable i would say right
um but uh but i enjoyed it and so and so
that kind of got me started down that
path
and um you know and then you know got
promoted fairly fairly
quickly into different kind of bigger
bigger teams
and um and then uh simple got acquired
by oracle
uh back in uh what was in 2006.
and so that was a time for me to kind of
say pause and uh
and say okay what's next um you know
oracle
nothing yeah i don't want to disparage
the company in any way but it was never
on my list
of hey this is a company that i wanted
to work for right now
relatively large organization and that
wasn't what
really appealed to me i really liked the
small team kind of the startup
entrepreneurial side of things
so um so i decided to stay at oracle
post the acquisition but
go back and fulfill an earlier part of
my desire in my career which was
get a understanding of the other side of
the business um i when i did my computer
science
undergrad at um at cal i also
my plan was to do a double major in
business and as many plans that one
didn't come to complete fruition but i
did a minor
so you settled for an mba at wharton
right
yeah that's right that's right so i
decided to do the nba award
it was actually kind of a funny uh funny
story because i made it
it was one of those things that you know
you make you think about it for years
but then you make a decision on a dime
right and so i made a decision i think
within like a couple of weeks
of the application due date wow and i
remember my family and i were going to
tahoe
um over over the holiday break in
december
and that was when the applications were
due and so i was busy you know writing
my
my entrance entrance uh essay uh
for why they should take me as uh you
know my friends and family were skiing
of course but anyway that was so so
organ was a great experience
particularly
coming from such a heavy tech background
um i
had a really hard time understanding
what the other side of the business did
i
looked at like sales and marketing as
overhead and what are those guys doing
you know we're doing all the hard stuff
we're building everything
um you know they're out there you know
trying to you know have drinks and
dinner with customers
right and and you know living life while
while you know we're paying their bills
while we're also working our building
but we being the education of the
company so
so i figure that's probably what not you
know there's some there's something
there that i wanted to understand better
so working gave me i think a great
perspective on that
is um it was a really rewarding
experience
um you know i would i would do it again
in a heartbeat if i had the chance
you know part of the appeal to me was
again i just love learning so much that
this was just an intense period of
learning where
i was i was spending 20 hours a week
probably
outside of you know while working at
oracle uh and uh
and doing classes and meetings and all
that amazing tremendous amount of fun um
i love that
ariel when did you get excited about
scaling this the the id
the word scale
um well i mean it was almost you know
it's it's funny you say that because
it was never really um something i kind
of pursued
it was almost like something in the
background that has that had to be done
right it's almost like good design uh
it's not really something you
at least for me wasn't something i kind
of got passionate about but
you know as i went through these
different experiences it was something
that i started developing
more and more experience in whether it's
whether it's starting from small
companies and building them into larger
teams and
companies or um you know or it was a
technical side of scaling and you know
starting out with you know a handful of
users that are mostly your friends and
family and then going to you know
thousands and millions of users
like that was um that was almost
something that had to be done that you
kind of think about your success and
pre-plan for your success early on
rather than kind of a path that i
followed so netflix i think netflix was
the time
when that
understanding of scaling and how to
build you know scalable and distributed
systems
um really uh uh emerged
for me i mean you're leading yeah you're
the director of cloud solutions and
at netflix and one of the most heavy
consumers
of the of what of any cloud
infrastructure you can imagine
i mean that must be a crazy experience
in terms of scale and in terms of
responsibility to understand
how to operate at scale right i mean
this is unprecedented scale
yeah i mean in netflix i had you know i
had the luxury of actually working at a
place like netflix and netflix you know
i got to tell you if you don't already
know it's just an incredible company
yeah um the management um the management
culture there and just the
the kind of people that the company is
able to attract i we read there i think
200 i've never been in any other
organization where i felt
the team was um well i think that back
there were maybe one other one other
time when we had like a group of 10
people that were like you know the most
the highest you know best people in the
company who kind of put together for a
small project but outside of that in any
kind of scale
uh you know a thousand engineers i think
was roughly the size of the organization
wow they're netflix
and working you know everyone you go to
is just like
knows what they're doing expert and not
just that but also like a mature
individual
wow not somebody that has to be uh we we
read for
for one of my classes at stanford we
read their i don't know like 70 or 100
page slide deck about culture
they're cultured like unbelievable that
was i mean that was just incredible to
see
yeah yeah i mean i'll tell you i finally
let you know you want stories
i'll tell you a funny story um before
netflix i was at a company called
cengevity
which was um also a pretty cool company
they were doing uh
residential solar and uh and you know my
team was was responsible for technology
which
um which which um was the first time in
in the industry that
allowed homeowners to get a solar system
designed for their roofs
without ever having a contractor come
out to their homes and measure it right
so
wow aerial satellite imagery would
create three-dimensional models
and and kind of design and then have a
remote source you could assign it but
that's less relevant uh you know i was
on the management team there i was
running
um uh the the technology part of the
business
and the last executive uh
management team meeting that i was in in
the company
uh was all of us sitting down and
reviewing
the netflix culture slides as a
management team
and saying this is you know this is a
great set of culture slides you know
aspirationally what can we
what can we pick from these things to to
incorporate into our organization
amazing
and then you know a month or two later i
think it was uh i was i was at the
company of netflix so
that was uh those wow serendipitous and
it wasn't it was funny enough it wasn't
even planned
so it wasn't i didn't actually uh go and
apply there i uh
i connected to somebody at a social uh
gathering
uh who was who was working there and and
he got kind of introduced
wow um so yeah so netflix uh the the
picture of scaling there was just
incredible um and i'd say not just from
the technical side also organizationally
like the way that they were able to
scale the
the you know this freedom and
responsibility culture there which i
still
you know to this day kind of quote and
love um is
is one that i just i haven't seen
effective anywhere else
right and that just empowers individuals
to do just amazing things
wow that's incredible okay so i want to
move on to to scale venture partners
because i think
the work that you're doing there is is
really incredible and and your expertise
on
on on you know the the industries you're
focused on and i'd love for you to tell
me a little bit more what does it mean
what is scale venture partners and what
is it about
you know cloud infrastructure cyber
security the companies you invest in why
are you so excited about that
because you know you're also coming in
from a very you know management
background and
and not too many people who go also the
management route have that
have that passion for cyber security and
infrastructure yet you seem to have
that interesting uh junction of the both
of them
yeah um as with most things um you know
some was by design
and some was some was you know just kind
of the path that ended up being taken
um so you know first i'll give you uh
you know a blurb about scale
um scale you know it's been around for a
few decades now i
joined you know thankfully a team that
was fully formed and and
and extremely successful so that was you
know that was a wonderful organization
to join that was already i was already
successful in in doing great things
um so i joined in 2013 and i was doing
fun uh for uh uh for for the firm and
we're now currently on fund six and you
know
we'll at some point be raising fund
seven the um
the mission of the firm is really to
help companies once they
uh build a product and have some initial
market validation to take those early
revenues
and scale it and build it into a big
business right so the term scale that
refers to
scaling organizations scaling revenues
scaling businesses
um so what we don't invest in is
typically the seed stage when
right you know folks coming out of
university and they have an idea
uh or out of uh or out of industry and
they have an idea and they want some
capital in order to build that
like that's the part of the market that
we don't address from a capital
standpoint but once they spend their you
know 6
12 18 months whatever right building
getting some initial design partners
getting some some market validation and
some early revenues that's where we get
involved typically series a series b
series c's um different stages and
that's in that scaling phase
and and help them kind of build those
revenues and uh and a lot of what the
firm's resources are
oriented around is how do you avoid some
of the common scaling mistakes
you know when do you hire when's the
right time to hire what what are some of
the what are some of these biggest
mistakes
most of the most often the time the
answer is uh you know
when you think it's the time to hire it
means probably it's too late you should
have started six months ago
i've been hearing that so much it's so
interesting yeah and when do you start
building some of these processes in
place around understanding
uh conversion around understanding um
you know your pipeline generation all
this is kind of the the go to market
side
of the business which is usually the the
set of systems that you have to build
after you've built the product and
you've been successful getting a product
market
so um so that's the that's the um the
the idea of scale and um you know and
and we've had the
the i guess the uh you know i'd say park
luck
part uh uh uh you know our own
uh picking uh you know to be so i
selected some you know great companies
uh to be part of the portfolio and and
um you know some great successes in the
past something
something i'm particularly proud of um
so when you when you do join a company
and you join their journey as they're
about to scale so let's say
they're raising their series they they
have some paying customers they've had
a market validation and they're ready to
scale their product and to grow it
how do you what is what role do you take
in in helping them do that are you more
of a sort of
you know as a bystander who's just
overlooking and and giving them a yay or
nay
do you are you very active in looking at
their plan and talking to their
customers and understanding
whether they actually have market
validation or if they're if they're just
you know
under the under the false assumption
where do you fit in there
yeah um we talk to a lot of customers
before
we make the investment so that's
typically part of our diligence process
is to understand
is there really a fit there is a product
market fit there and so we do you know
we'll talk to
a dozen a couple dozen different
customers both customers as well as
prospects as well as you know folks in
our own network who write typical buyers
um and to kind of validate that there's
a there's a product market fit there so
that that typically happens before we
make the investment
until we get to that level of companies
and by the way is that easier as you're
more concentrated on a specific industry
so if you're concentrated on cloud
infrastructure and cyber security
because it's it's the same players come
up quite often right
well that's one and then the other is um
you just have a much better um ability
to
determine the quality of the answers
you're getting right
of course so you know you can kind of
put people in the bucket of these folks
understand it because
you know they kind of understand the
complexities of the world and when it
comes to infrastructure and there might
be early adopters
and early signals or these folks are you
know just going to do
what they read about in in in the
technical 100
and and then you know that gives you a
different type of
data so i certainly think the having
that
experience you know i think i think lets
you
um understand where the market is going
maybe a few months
you know a few quarters earlier than
when it would be otherwise
obvious so um so back to your question
around you know how involved we get
i mean the answer is fairly involved and
this is something that i personally find
extremely satisfying and rewarding
about this role is you know i don't i
don't want to be there kind of sitting
once a quarter kind of saying yay or nay
you know do this or don't do this and
because that's you know i don't think
that's
as effective um in the areas where
i feel like i can add value um i get
fairly involved and those you know those
those kind of fall into
a couple of different buckets one is
well what's the expertise of the firm
that's certainly something that we have
a lot of resources and and
personal experience with and that's
around how do you scale revenues and how
do you
build some of these systems i mentioned
and then the other side is around just
the product and technical
side of it and and that's that's
something that i think i bring
uniquely from my own background in
understanding how to
build engineering teams understanding
how to uh you know build products
and uh and even some of the technical
and scale inside of it you know one of
the first things i did when i started
scale before i could really add any
value on the venture side
uh because i was completely new to
venture when i first joined is i went
around to different portfolio companies
and essentially gave them
my my talk that i used to give at
netflix around hey how do you build
large-scale distributed systems that are
fault-tolerant and brazilian okay and um
and that was something that was very
valuable to those engineering teams
but also to you because you got you got
to experience the full companies
potentially
in a deeper way than a lot of other
partners do because from understanding
also the
you know part not every partner is
involved with every with every company
and you got to sort of understand the
portfolio a little bit better ariel
you know in the last minute that we have
are there specific
places that the market is going to that
you're especially excited about that you
know young people coming out of 8200 or
stanford could be thinking of
in the realms of cloud infrastructure
cyber security the world has changed
dramatically over the past few months
where do you what are some of you know
the the key places that you think
bright minds should put their should put
their effort
you know that's a really good question
and i um you know i can give you an
answer to that question
but my first um reaction to that would
be you know don't listen to anything
that a venture capitalist or investor
tells you uh we should be the area that
you're focusing on because honestly
you know even either you know i come
from a fairly technical background but
it's now you know seven years since i've
been an operator
and my information is you know it's got
it's got a you know fairly fast decay
right right so whatever i think it is
it's probably things that i've heard
from others
and you know what i would encourage
folks to do is understand
from their own vantage point you know
where are uh
gaps in the market and then build to
that because
you know it's it's those folks that are
in the trenches that are building it
that are
um you know understanding where those
where those challenges lie that i think
they're the best positions and you know
we
kind of figure it out later after you
know after after it's been built
after their customers already tell us
that this is something that's uh
so so that would be my my initial answer
you know in terms of
in terms of specific areas um i
i think the cloud infrastructure side of
things is just extremely nascent
at this point we're in the very very
early days of having
uh you know we've kind of just released
you know vms right
as a technology when it comes to when it
comes to you know fast forward to to the
equipment in the infrastructure so
every every company that's doing
anything in a reasonable scale from an
engineering standpoint needs to build
its own platform from
you know from the ground up and you know
usually construct it in different pieces
so i'm still
waiting to see who will solve this
problem who is going to come up with
a way of building uh cloud native
applications where you don't
have to custom build to aws and gcp
and and azure and you know you don't
have to worry about scaling up uh
ec2 instances and you don't have to
worry about setting up uh security
groups and and elbs and so on so
like that piece of it i think is still
missing um so that's one that i'm
you know always on the lookout for um on
the infrastructure side
um you know the other side of it i think
there's also around
various parts in the development life
cycle right i hear that a lot yeah
yeah as the infrastructure changes the
you know management and orchestration
and kind of workflow piece of it has to
change as well so
you know whether it's in uh you know
software quality
or in deployment each one of those
pieces there's
every time there's a there's a shift in
the underlying infrastructure
the management side of it has to be 100
you know as a software engineer myself
going through these processes and
working on a variety of projects
both professionally academically i
definitely see that as a huge huge
potential and
a place that i that i'm that i'm
personally very excited about
ariel before we leave i have to ask you
the hardest question
putting on the spot one last time three
words that you would use to describe
yourself for that any of your partners
at scale venture partners
would describe you as i don't want to
answer that question i hate talking
about myself and and certainly is
not not um not not something i enjoy
well that's that's definitely i think a
valuable answer on its own
maybe maybe maybe i'll say curious i'll
take i'll take curious curious
curious is good enough for all three and
i and i appreciate their response and i
think that's
that's also something that that is i
think quite quite interesting
with people who are really excited about
about about helping others accomplish
things and watching a lot of great
people around them succeed
and and and and i truly truly appreciate
it ariel thank you for your time to
daraba
and thank you very much i mean i'll
leave i'll leave your listeners with one
last thought which is
i think you know everybody who's who's
your peer right now is at an incredible
place in life that you don't get to
experience very often you're around the
world
the world is your opportunity right now
and so you know don't listen to
everybody that says no for every one of
your ideas because you're going to get
you know 100
notes for every every you know yes you
get so you know have the passion have
the
have the conviction to you know do what
you believe in and i think that
you'll have an incredible time in your
life a hundred percent ariel
thank you very much thanks bye-bye